speaking of getting too soft did you see
that there was a news story that came
out recently about the treatment of
seals during their selection process do
you see this yeah I saw it yeah they
were getting sprayed with tear gas
whilst they were on the ground and they
were made to sing Happy Birthday so that
they couldn't hold their breath while it
was happening and there was a quote from
this guy I think this type of training
is really senseless said Sven yort a
Duke University associate professor who
studies tear gas and its effects it
looks more like a form of hazing right I
see all that trust me like I said you
know
I'm not gonna sugarcoat anything
I understand that guy
I understand exactly where you're coming
from
that is your personal opinion and I
totally get that
but
there's very few people in this world
who want to do a job like that
and it takes a different kind of mindset
is it tear grass appropriate I don't
know
how hard that training is I don't expect
anybody to understand it but one percent
but the loud voices of this world are
the 99 who don't understand exactly what
you have to do that's why when I speak
and you don't understand me it's
probably a good thing
because that probably means
I'm in an area of life that you're not
in which is fine
that's why I don't judge people and this
guy right here judging that unless
you've been there and done that and you
really can't speak about it unless
you're in those situations that are so
hard that takes a special human being to
get through them I think it's the same
kind of feeling that I get when I heard
about Elon Musk telling the employees at
Twitter
we're going to ask you to work harder
than you've ever worked in your life
yeah this is a place Twitter is now a
company where people can go if they want
to be in the top naught Point not not
one percent of hard-working programmers
and software developers on the planet
that's right and there was everybody was
up in arms this is unbelievable we're
going back to this old version of
capitalism where the the worker is being
abused and used and thrown away what
they didn't account for is that there is
a non-insignificant cohort of people for
whom that's their dream that's right
people who want to be able to get up on
a morning having gone to bed four hours
before and can contribute to some sort
of progress that they think
this this is what I'm here for yep and
it's the same with the seals if you're
not the sort of person that is built to
go through selection
it's like speaking a different language
that's it and that's why I don't try to
convince people otherwise I understand
that why you're confused
I understand why you say things like
that I'm not saying anything bad about
that
I understand it but also what you don't
understand what you fail to understand
is the other side that you need people
like that you need the Elon musks you
need the David Goggins you need some of
these Navy Seals some of these other
people you need those people
and they don't they forget that and it
takes a very very unique
person and unique mind to do some of
these jobs that are necessary in this
world well especially when we're
thinking about someone going to war
right do you want your Armed Forces to
be underprepared for the battlefield
because he didn't want to be too mean to
them in advance
that's that's the problem that's the
problem and that's a problem that I've
always had
I've always had is that right there is
that with even even some of the most
trained people in the world
fall back on that it's easy to talk
about like I said
when you go through it once
we it's a perishable skill
hardness
mental hardening mental toughness it's a
perishable skill
just because you went through some
training once and you got through it
doesn't mean it lasts forever and that's
where most people hated me
in my life because I realized that
you don't just say oh I got it I'm
checked off I'm good for rest of my life
that's why you have a recall you recall
from everything
and you definitely must recall when it
comes to the mind
that is one of the biggest
re-qualifications you must have and when
you're at that level you gotta recall
every day not once a year this episode
is brought to you by element element is
a tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't I've replaced my morning
coffee with element every day for over
three years now and I've never looked
back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink
lmnt.com
modern wisdom thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that clip with
Goggins then press here for the full
episode in all of its glory and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]